give us a diagram here and they give us
the Givens which basically are hints or
clues so when you see the Givens that's
a hint and then they tell us what you
they want us to prove okay so let's see
what we have here we have that w y
equals x Z so that means this whole
length here is equal to this whole
length here okay so I put some brackets
just to show that but what we want to
prove is that W X is equal to Y Z okay
so my suggestion to you is that when
you're doing these proofs try to jump
into that diagram and mark it up so that
you can see what's happening so you
don't have to remember it you know while
you're doing the proof you can just
visually look at it now what you can see
is that these two segments that are
congruent or equal they overlap and what
they share in common is this segment
here X Y so if those two things are
equal and then we subtract off something
that's in common between those two
segments we should be left with what's
left over which is W X is then equal to
Y Z does that make sense okay so let's
go through the proof step by step now
we're doing two column proofs there's
different types of proofs like paragraph
proofs and flow proofs but in this
example I'm just going to do a two
column proof okay the statements on this
side and the reasons or the
justifications on the right side so
generally I usually write the Givens
first just to kind of get that out of
the way and it just gets me started with
the the proof kind of it gets me going
and whatever you're trying to prove
that's always going to be the last step
okay so what we're trying to do is fill
in those intermediate or in-between
steps okay so you're with me so far okay
so the first thing that I'm going to do
here is I'm going to state that W X plus
X y equals W Y okay so if w ax plus XY
equals W Y and over here we also have X
y plus y Z equals X Z so XY plus y Z
equals XZ and what's the reason for that
well that's called the segment addition
postulate but two segments added
together add up to the whole segment
okay so that's the idea there with a
segment addition postulate so that's our
reason and notice that I combine these
into the same step because they have the
same reason so segment addition posh
I'm just gonna abbreviate here okay now
step number three so what I'm going to
do and this might seem a little bit
obvious but it's good to state it
anyways and that's that XY segment XY is
equal to segment XY okay and how do I
know that well that's called the
reflexive property reflexive is like
looking in a mirror you see your
reflection you're the same height in the
mirror as you are in real life right so
that's called the reflexive property
this X Y is equal to itself and you'll
see why that we're going to do that in a
minute or use that in a minute and then
step number four what we're going to do
is we're going to state that and follow
me on this one so sometimes what we're
doing is we're getting information from
the diagram sometimes we're getting
information from the Givens and then
sometimes we're actually using previous
steps in our proof okay so for example
here cwy see how it equals WX plus XY
what I'm going to do is I'm going to put
it right there okay and do you know what
the reason is for that and then also for
this one X Z see how it equals x y plus
y Z so I'm going to put that right there
so what allows me to do that you know
the answer to that
well that's called substitution and a
lot of these proofs you're gonna be
using the property of substitution if
two things are equal it's just like a
substitute teacher if your math teacher
isn't there one day because they're off
oftentimes they have a substitute math
teacher and they just swap them out
right so that's just a little funny way
of remembering okay so but basically
what we have now is we did a
substitution since the two quantities
are equal we replace one with the other
and that brought us to this step right
here so this was a substitution
substitution okay now notice that we
have an XY on both sides of the equal
sign right so let's go ahead and jump to
step number five which is what we're
trying to prove and that's that WX
equals Y Z now how was I able to
eliminate the XY on both sides of this
equation well that's called the
subtraction property of equality just
like in algebra when you subtracted 9
from the left side and 9 from the right
side it keeps the equation balanced it's
the same thing here we're subtracting X
Y from both sides of the equation so it
keeps it balanced and that's called the
subtraction property of equality I'm
just abbreviate
but you can write it out subtraction
property of equality if you do the same
thing to both sides subtraction it's
still going to be equal and that's what
we were trying to prove so that's our
last step so we've completed it and
again going back to this step where we
stated that XY equals XY it's kind of
obvious but because we're subtracting
the same thing from both sides it's just
good to say that you know it's equal to
itself so when we go to subtract it from
both sides
we're doing the same thing to both sides
of the equation so you could have made
this proof maybe a little bit longer or
maybe even a little bit shorter by you
know possibly leaving out some of these
steps but it doesn't hurt to just take
tiny tiny steps a lot of times when
students are first getting into these
proofs they want to just jump right from
the beginning to the end and one step or
two steps and you really want to break
it down into smaller steps okay just
like you know really baby steps like
that so I hope this helps you to
understand how to do just a basic proof
I'm gonna have some more videos like
this talking about beginning proofs so
go ahead and check those all out to get
more familiar with how to do these
geometry proofs subscribe to the channel
and I look forward to seeing the future
videos I'll talk to you soon